[Music]
there's a lot of excitement this crowd
i'll tell you why tonight the la kings
could win the stanley cup and that's
that's crazy
yeah
it's true people in los angeles haven't
been this excited since they watched
their first hockey game on monday
what a bandwagon town
show by a plus you had no idea we had a
hockey team yeah yeah here you go
[Applause]
that's the one with the ice in the puck
right wait i thought that was curling
president obama is in town and there's a
rumor that president obama is going to
stop by tonight's l.a kings hockey game
yeah
yeah the president doesn't want to draw
attention to himself he just wants to
blend in with all the other black
hawaiian hockey fans
no one will notice yeah
this is crazy someone hacked into mitt
romney's email account did you hear this
they hacked into his email account after
correctly guessing the answer to his
security question
they guessed it apparently the the
question was who was your first grade
teacher and romney responded who cares
i've got 200 million dollars
[Applause]
this is the crazy thing it was revealed
that mitt romney's email address is
mittromney hotmail.com
that's true
yeah the guy who's trying so hard to
prove he's in touch is still using
hotmail
that's my favorite part
you excited about the olympics coming up
[Music]
the olympic torch is on its way to
london today the torch entered ireland
yeah the torch the torch was only in
ireland for three hours but somehow it
managed to punch a cop and get two girls
pregnant
in nine months they'll give birth to two
little cigarette lighters uh
hey new
thanks for the assist on that one pal
morning after pill very controversial
yeah some experts are saying that the
morning after pill has become so
politically divisive it should be given
a different name
yeah right now the uh the name
conservatives are pushing is flintstones
chewables for [ __ ]
[Applause]
you thought about it you're like that is
a good name
everyone talking about this dc comics
has announced that the green lantern is
their first major superhero who's gay
yeah green heroes gay
when reached for comment aquaman said
yeah maybe on land [ __ ]
it's true though this is big news dc
comics has announced the green lantern's
gay
yeah not to be outdone marvel comics has
started having the incredible hulk smash
through walls using jazz hands
hug smash
[Applause]
did you hear this the octomom was going
to uh appear in a strip club did you
hear about that
okay picture that in your mind
well the octomom's appearance of the
strip club has been canceled it's not
going to
apparently they realize those weren't
tassels spinning on her nipples those
were babies
[Applause]
[Music]
new babies are reattaching after the
other ones are launched
thank you
no
no that's
you're too kind
taco bell is launching a new upscale
menu at all their new locations isn't
that nice
upscale menu at taco bell
that's good news for anyone who's ever
wanted to experience classy diarrhea
[Applause]
it's got glitter in it i know
[Laughter]
ah
good show tonight huh
we've taken the temperature of the show
and it's just the kind we like that's
right